remember remember the fifth of November
the gunpowder treason and plot I know of
no reason why the gunpowder treason
should ever be forgot on November the
5th 1605 thirteen men plotted together
to blow up the Palace of Westminster in
London on the day when the most powerful
men in England were set to meet a
parliament the authorities learned about
the plan through an anonymous letter and
the terrorists were stopped just in time
the man they encountered at the scene
was Guy Fawkes who had been guarding
barrels of gunpowder in the basement
below the palace if you're an American
you probably know about Guy Fawkes from
the movie V for Vendetta and you most
likely associate him with Anarchy this
association has been pushed even more in
recent years with the use of Guy Fawkes
masks by the Anonymous organization if
you're from the UK you already know
about Guy Fawkes night which is
celebrated every November the fifth with
a bonfire and fireworks nearly everyone
has heard of the famous Gunpowder
applause but few people know details
about Guy Fawkes his life or the
motivations behind why he and his
friends wanted to blow up Parliament in
the first place even though this is a
biography of his life Guy Fawkes is
really a very small part of the larger
story in order to fully understand the
motivations behind the Gunpowder Plot
we first need to examine the conflicts
between English Catholics and
Protestants at that time for a large
part of human history the most powerful
religion in the world was the Roman
Catholic Church if a country was
Catholic its citizens looked up to the
reigning Pope as their religious leader
and in the minds of some this Authority
was more important than the loyalty to
the actual king or queen because whoever
has access to God has access to your
mortal soul in a lot of ways the
Protestant Reformation was a way to
remove all of the power being held by
the Pope's and bishops it was sort of
like cutting out the middleman for the
average person's access to God because
you see Catholics are taught that if you
want your sins to be forgiven you have
to tell a priest every bad thing you've
ever done in
fashion a priest is sworn to secrecy
kind of like a therapist
but even so everyone had the knowledge
that these men held all of the deepest
darkest secrets of their congregation a
confession it wasn't just encouraged
it's mandatory and even the smallest sin
left unsaid could mean you're going to
hell on top of that Catholic Mass was
set in laughs and so everyone needed to
study the language for the uneducated
peasants they needed to rely on a
translation from their priest basically
the religion is set up in a way where
priests and the Pope were given a huge
amount of power over their congregation
in 1558 Elizabeth declared that there
should be a settlement which declared
all English citizens must convert to
Protestantism bishops that were formerly
a part of the Catholic Church must
renounce their loyalty to the Pope if
they wanted to live it was now mandatory
for every English person to go to
Protestant church services every Sunday
and they were taking attendance
if anyone missed one too many services
they were fined or even sent to jail
after hearing about this Pope Pius v
excommunicated Elizabeth from the
Catholic Church in 1570 he commanded a
papal bull that encouraged all Catholics
to de poseur basically this meant that
they should no longer be loyal to their
queen he called her Elizabeth the
pretended Queen of England and the
servant of crime you can probably see
why this was problematic because
Catholics in the country were now seen
as enemy agents people in the lower
classes they were quick to convert to
Protestantism they could not afford to
pay the hefty fines and many of the
illiterate peasants couldn't speak or
read Latin anyway it was an easy choice
to make and a symbol that they were
loyal to their queen but for the
educated people of the upper class this
was not such an easy conversion for one
thing this was taking away the freedom
to choose their religion and there were
plenty of people who still truly
believed that the Catholic Church was
the one true church these people they
were called recusants which comes from
the Latin word riku ser which means to
refuse for these people who broke the
lorentz continued to practice their
Catholic faith they believed that they
were fighting for their immortal souls
as quite the motivation since so much of
the religion relies on a priest to say
Mass and give confession recusing
Catholics began to hide priests in their
homes this it was completely illegal and
harboring a priest was punishable by
death
if a family was Catholic the Royal Guard
would show up unannounced at all times
of day and ransack their homes looking
for hidden priests upper-class Catholic
families who refused to attend
Protestant Mass they continued to pay
expensive fines to the point where they
were losing all of their family's
inheritance many English Catholics they
were forced to move to Flanders which
was a safe zone after Elisabeth the
firsts death the Scottish King James the
6th took over the throne and became King
James the first of England Catholic
citizens had no idea how his reign would
be any different than Elizabeth's and
they waited to see what would happen
next so there's not very much that is
known about guy Fox's charters except
that he was born in 1570 in York England
to Edward and Edith Fawkes
his family had been Protestant and his
father even worked for the Church of
England they were law-abiding
protestants who went to church every
Sunday his mother came from a long line
of Catholics but she chose to give up
her faith in favor of conforming Guy
Fawkes his father he died when he was 8
years old and his mother was a widow for
years before she decided to marry a
Catholic man they began practicing the
faith in secret and they baptized God
and his siblings in a secret ceremony in
decent Michel the belfry church he
attended San Peter's School in York
which had a lot of reducing Catholic
teachers and students he was able to
attend Mass in the homes of people who
were hiding priests as an adult he chose
to continue practicing that Catholic
faith and he became passionate about
trying to protect it at some point Guy
Fawkes is said to have gotten married
and had a son there are records from
1590 that a man named Guy Fawkes married
a woman named Maria palain and a birth
certificate shows that their son Thomas
Forks was born when Guy Fawkes was 21
years old he would have been old enough
to take out his inheritance that same
year there are documents of a lease and
a three and a half a piece of lands and
home being signed by Guy Fawkes
this included the stamp of an image with
a falcon which was his family crest he
entered the service of Anthony Brown the
first by count of Montague as a footman
at that time working in the service of
the Lord was considered to be a very
respectable job among the lower-class
especially compared to being a farmer
but for whatever reason Brown
did not like guy fawkes so he fired him
back then your reputation was everything
and it must have been difficult for him
to get another job without a good letter
of recommendation he managed to work for
Browns a grandson after Anthony Brown's
death from the records it would seem
that he struggled to maintain steady
employment so at 21 years old he left
England and moved to Flanders he fought
together with the Spanish army to do his
part in the 80 year war at that time
Spain was considered to be the protector
of the Catholic faith and during the war
they were fending off Dutch Protestants
in the Netherlands while fighting with
the Spanish he decided to go by the name
of guy doe he was described by one of
his compatriots to be of excellent good
natural parts very resolute and
universally learn it and was sought by
all the most distinguished in the
Archduke's camp for nobility and virtue
people say that he was very tall and
muscular
he had reddish brown hair and a beard
and was basically described as being the
perfect soldier despite having these
descriptions no one knows what Guy
Fawkes truly looks like because there
was never a portrait painted of his
likeness we only have the caricatures
that depicted him after his death and
these were mostly drawn in such a way
that made him look like a villain in
most images he has black hair and beard
with an upturned moustache
[Music]
after King James the first came into
power Catholics waited with bated breath
to see what would happen in next they're
accusing Catholic man named Thomas Percy
was a cousin of Henry Percy the eighth
Earl of Northumberland even though he
was not a lord himself Percy was able to
take it upon himself to request an
audience with the King he asked for
mercy on behalf of English Catholics
wanting to gain popularity with his new
English subjects James was vague and
made sure not to make any promises it
was still very early in his reign and he
was not sure yet what he should do about
the tensions between Protestants and
Catholics he essentially told Percy not
to worry because he personally had no
ill will towards Catholics Percy
believed that King James was going to
offer some kind of relief and that he
might be getting ready to repeal Queen
Elizabeth the first slaws Percy was very
happy about this and he returned to town
his friends and family that they no
longer had to worry about being
persecuted for their faith some even
hopes that maybe James would convert to
Catholicism and that the entire country
would revert back to practicing the one
true faith for about a year English
Catholics were able to live a normal
life James temporarily stopped
collecting fees that Rikki's and
Catholics were required to pay for
skipping the Protestant service he also
did not push for his guard to search
Catholic homes for Harvard priests
however the laws made by Elizabeth the
first were kept in place it not repealed
them because he was waiting to see what
the reaction would be from his
Protestant Parliament in the summer of
1604 the members of parliament they
finally noticed the Catholics were not
being persecuted anymore and their hands
push King James to come down hard on
them the way they felt about the
Catholics was similar to Communists in
the cold war many of them believed that
if they were not stamped out they would
cause an uprising
so James brought back the same laws that
Elizabeth the first had put in place
suddenly Catholic homes were being
searched once again and they were being
treated like criminals the Catholic
people in England they lived so long
being oppressed but the thing that
triggered their anger was the false
sense of hope they felt betrayed by King
James and it was enough to make son want
to kill him even though Guy Fawkes is
the one who is most remembered for the
Gunpowder Plot the ringleader was
actually a man named Robert Catesby he
began making plans in 1603 and first
recruited a man named Thomas winter
Catesby and winter they rode to Spain
because they had associates who were
Catholic that Spain was also
designated as the protector of the
Catholic faith since Catholics were
being persecuted once again they begged
for help from the Spanish to stop King
James from killing their people however
the Spanish they were not interested in
getting involved catsby in winter they
returned to England and decided if they
were going to find someone to help it
would have to be at home the people they
found were John Wright and Thomas Percy
winter had gone to school with Guy
Fawkes and he seemed like the perfect
candidate to help them out with the plot
after all Fork sent plenty of experience
fighting in Spain and he knew a lot
about gunpowder forks was smart and he
knew how to stay cool under pressure
in May of 1604 the five men were spotted
together at London's duck and Drake in
they whispered about their plot and they
swore an oath of loyalty and secrecy the
group was biding their time trying to
figure out the finer details of the plan
as time went on Thomas Percy had the
resources to purchase a property in
London that was very close to the Palace
of Westminster Guy Fawkes began to live
with him posing as a footman named John
Johnson this way that never seemed out
of the ordinary to anyone who witnessed
them around town at that time it was not
uncommon for men to buy Gunpowder
especially if they found to sell
overseas they needed the powder to use
their guns and cannons and defend
themselves from pirates if the only
problem was that they'd need to buy
small quantities over a long period of
time in order to not raise suspicions
the Guy Fawkes would use his connections
to slowly gather a cache of gunpowder
barrels that were left over from ships
entering the harbor and bring them back
to Thomas Percy at the time the Palace
of Westminster had a collection of
smaller buildings Lords and members of
the upper class would come and go from
these buildings on a regular basis
without being stopped by security the
rules were very relaxed and it was
actually easy for Thomas Percy to rent a
storage space in the basement below the
palace claiming that it was for his
cousin the Earl of Northumberland to
store firewood for winter the day of
Parliament kept getting delayed and the
group of conspirators grew from five to
thirty men unfortunately for them they
the extended time combines with the
greater number of people who were being
told about the plot men so that it was
far more likely that the secret was
going to get out a Catholic man named
Nord Monteagle was preparing to be
present at Parliament a masked man
handed a letter to one of montego's
servants and it was presented to him
immediately it said my lord out of the
love I bear to some of your friends
I have a care for your preservation
therefore I would advise you as you
tender your life to devise some excuse
to shift your attendance of this
Parliament for though there be no
appearance of any stir yet I say they
shall receive a terrible blow even
though it was late at night Lord
Monteagle quickly told his servants to
ready the horses so that he could
deliver the letter to Robert Cecil the
spymaster and secretary of state to King
James historians have debated over the
theories of who actually wrote the
anonymous letter it could have been one
of the 13 conspirators it may even have
been Monteagle himself writing a fake
letter after hearing letters through the
catholic recusing grapevine he was
awarded five hundred pounds per year for
his loyalty to the crown back then that
was a small fortune even more historians
believe that it was Robert Cecil
he was the spymaster after all and some
believe that he knew about the Gunpowder
Plot for a long time and orchestrated
the entire scene to make himself seem
like the hero on the 4th of November
there was an extensive search of the
Palace of Westminster at first they
didn't find anything that concerned them
and they were beginning to believe that
the letter was a hoax but later that day
it was brought to the raw guards
attention that there were cellars
underneath the palace that had not yet
been searched a royal official named Sir
Thomas knivert was told that one of them
was being used for storing firewood so
he led a group of wronged guards to
search the area when they arrived they
found Guy Fawkes guarding the firewood
instead of wearing the clothes of a
watchman Fawkes was dressed in his
riding boots Spurs hat and cloak as if
he was getting ready to jump on a horse
at any moment they moved the wood piles
aside to reveal 36 barrels of gunpowder
the raw guards searched him and found a
box of long matches forks he was
immediately arrested on November the 6th
King James wanted to meet Guy Fawkes
face-to-face he interviewed him asking
if he had any regret he genuinely wanted
to know how anyone could be so ruthless
and be willing to kill so many people
even the young children who would have
been present at Parliament Forks said
that his only regret was that his plan
had failed Fox still called himself John
Johnson and he refused to give up the
names of his co-conspirators King James
ordered the fork speak tortured and
interrogated he was suspended by
manacles and then put on the rack so
that his arms and legs were stretched
and popped out of their sockets
he eventually caved since
gave us confession in the
before-and-after of his signature we can
see that he could hardly write his own
name after enduring so much pain while
guy Forks was being tortured the rest of
the conspirators they were on the run
Robert Catesby begins he announced the
villagers that King James was dead and
he called for the Catholics to rise up
and reclaim their rightful place in the
kingdom
they rode from town to town but instead
of the huge army he expected there were
only about forty men who decided to
follow him ironically Caspian his men
they accidentally blew themselves up
with their own gunpowder that they'd
brought with them without Guy Fawkes
there to help them with his expertise
they thought that in order to dry out
the damp they should sprinkle their
gunpowder in front of an open fireplace
it exploded of course and one of the men
went blind
the rest were now burned and injured one
man asked Robert catsby what they were
going to do next he replied we mean here
to die one of em of the 8th the sheriff
of Warwickshire showed up with a small
army of 200 men there was a shootout
between the two groups The Weeknd's
Catholic men did their best to go out
fighting but it was clear that the
Kingsguard was gonna work with how of
them Rama catsby was shot but he crawled
to the nearby chapel he was found on the
floor of the church parking a statue of
the Virgin Mary the men who were left
alive were taken prisoner and sentenced
to hang in the gallows along with Guy
Fawkes
on the 31st of January 1606 Guy Fawkes
and his fellow conspirators were found
guilty of treason and their punishments
would have been to be hanged drawn and
quartered this meant that a man was
dragged through the streets before he
was hanged in the gallows but just
before he was about to choke to death
they would let him go as he gasped for
breath they would dig a knife into his
stomach and pull out his entrails then
they chopped off his arms and his legs
while he was still alive then the four
quarters of the body were taken to the
four corners of England as Guy Fawkes
stood in the crowd
King James declared that these Catholic
traitors were trying to blow up the
entire island of England's this would
have been physically impossible of
course but it was enough to make the
people extremely angry they were
screaming and booing calling him a
traitor before they could torture in Guy
Fawkes jumped
breaking his own neck even though it was
not alive to fill the pain they still
went through with cutting his body apart
into pieces the Gunpowder Plot very
nearly succeeded and if it were not for
an anonymous letter Guy Fawkes may have
actually succeeded at lighting the fuse
if the barrels of gunpowder had exploded
it would have been powerful enough to
bring down the palace and the nearby
buildings it would have killed the king
and the princess as well as some of the
most powerful noblemen in the country
this would have left the throne to
James's daughter Princess Elizabeth they
had hoped that since she was so young
she would be easy to manipulate as a
sort of puppet many believe that Robert
can Smee would have eventually gotten
more Catholics to follow him and this
would have erupted into an English Civil
War after this incident parliament
passed the thanksgiving act of 1606
which was a law that English citizens
must pray and give thanks to God that
the terrorists did not kill the king
that date became known as Guy Fawkes
night or bonfire night and it's
celebrated every year on November the
5th people usually celebrate by building
a large bonfire and burning life-size
dummies of Guy Fawkes there is also a
fireworks show to symbolize the
explosions that never happened since
then everyone has always remembered the
5th of November so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
do not forget to subscribe we got brand
new videos just like this several times
a week if you look for something else to
watch from me why not check out my other
channel called highlight history you'll
find a link to that below and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]